[Musik]
[Applaus]
die legende
und hier inmitten der norditalienischen
provinz bologna im beschaulichen ort
sant'agata bolognese hat sie ihre
wurzeln hier steht die edelschmiede mit
dem stier die ikone italienische
automobil technik
im jahr 1964 entschloss sich ferruccio
lamborghini die besten sport autos der
welt zu bauen ein kühnes unterfangen nur
wenige kilometer von ferrari entfernt
doch schon sein erstes modell der 350 gt
städte die roten aus maranello weit in
den schatten auch die nachfolger wie
jura espada und yamaha setzten akzente
doch nicht nur technisch überzeugten
seine entwürfe auch im styling und
interviewer war er seiner zeit voraus
[Musik]
seine automobile sind extravagant und
extraordinär die speerspitze im
futuristischen automobilbau
bis heute hat die marke nichts an ihrer
faszination und ihren mythos verloren
die legende lamborghini lebt in den
aktuellen modellen gallardo und
murciélago weiter
und er ist wahrhaft eine lebende legende
valentino balboni er war einer der
ersten testfahrer von ferruccio
lamborghini und kennt seine geschichte
wie kein anderer
das wir gebaut haben
der 350 gt
und der stil ist die bis von die
sechziger und siebziger jahren und
molina weltexklusiv seien mit seinem
auto und und besonders der gewicht wenn
sie ist die erste super liter auto das
wir gebaut haben mit aluminiumkarosserie
und da wären wir besonders die erste
hauptrunde gemacht und ferrari so ärgern
in der folge hatten die designer und
ingenieure der konkurrenz öfters anlass
sich zu ärgern zwar waren nicht alle
modelle aus der feder von ferruccio
lamborghini auch wirtschaftlich
erfolgreich doch es gelang ihm bei jeder
innovation die aufmerksamkeit und das
interesse auf sich zu ziehen jeder
lamborghini seinerzeit war auch eine
schlagzeile
so auch der reventón auf 22 stück
reduziert war er bei seiner präsentation
im jahr 2007 mit 650 ps das
leistungsstärkste serienfahrzeug der
welt
letztlich haben wir dieses hightech
fahrzeug auf vier rädern einer
privatfehde zwischen enzo ferrari und
ferruccio lamborghini zu verdanken
[Musik]
so verriet sie war immer unzufrieden mit
dieser konkurrenz auto und er hat einen
tag
in so vereine getroffen und ein bisschen
mit inso ferrari diskutiert insofern hat
ihm gesagt du bist ein traktor bauern du
bist ein bauer und du bist ein traktoren
fahren
du musst nicht mit mit unserem it meine
wunderschöne verehre beschweren du bist
ein traktorfahrer und obst anbauen und
rosa molina war wirklich böse und hat
ihm gesagt ist fein jahren mit meiner
mit meine einzige autor und oulu und du
willst sehen wie wie ein sportler sein
muss
aus einer manufaktur für
landwirtschaftliche geräte wuchs über
die jahrzehnte eines der modernsten
zentren für sportwagen technologie
hinter einer schwarzen fassade verbirgt
sich das herzstück des unternehmens die
designabteilung hier werden die träume
und visionen der zukunft auf papier und
bildschirm gebracht
lamborghini ist eine edelschmiede erster
güte entsprechend sorgfältig und
zeitaufwendig gestaltet sich auch die
entwicklung wer hier arbeitet zählt zur
creme de la creme im automobilbau
entsprechend begehrt sind die plätze
gerade bei jungen designern in der
erlesenen runde arbeiten zu dürfen
[Musik]
als designer kreieren wir hier jeden tag
träume autos von denen die menschen die
nächsten jahre träumen werden oder
vielleicht noch länger
wir entwickeln hier die nächste
generation unserer modelle und ich bin
sehr stolz diese aufgabe umsetzen zu
dürfen
die kreativen köpfe arbeiten unter einem
enormen erfolgsdruck schließlich müssen
sie sich mit jedem design neu erfinden
und dennoch dem image und der tradition
treu bleiben
diabolo mozilla gallardo das sind alles
namen die sich bei uns tief festgesetzt
haben und wir versuchen bei jedem modell
eine ähnliche ikone zu schöpfen
das ist wirklich nicht einfach
aber diese männer hier sind in der lage
dieses außergewöhnliche auto zu
entwickeln und ich bin mir sicher dass
unsere designabteilung auch in zukunft
so erfolgreich sein wird wie bisher
wie anfang der 60 er wird auch heute aus
ein paar strichen auf papier eines der
teuersten autos der welt
das hier ist ein typisches beispiel für
unser design das sich auch in unserer
aktuellen produktpalette befindet sehr
aggressiv und kompromisslos
wie sie sehen arbeiten wir hier mit
seiner markanten konturen zum einen
hierbei der motorhaube aber auch hier an
den flanken und wir arbeiten auch mit
kontrastreichen farbkompositionen und
mit einer klaren botschaft
dieses auto soll sehr gefährlich
aussehen und das kommunizieren wir mit
den farben schwarz und gelb sowie der
gestaltung des hecks der frontflügel
aber auch der lufteinlässe
das ist unsere bildsprache für einen
lamborghini
und sie kommunizieren mit dieser sprache
auch eine sehr reservierte modellpolitik
über die chefdesigner manfred fitzgerald
wacht
ich glaube produktpaletten erweiterungen
ja da kommen darüber reden ob es jetzt
einen geländewagen wird das glaube ich
wer momentan nicht auf betont wir haben
viele szenarien auf dem tisch gehabt und
durchgesprochen und wir hatten ja vor
zwei jahren in paris ja ein ein schocker
dargestellt an viertürigen limousine da
haben wir gezeigt was in der marke
steckte und vielleicht einen ein morgen
werden wir auch dahin gehen kommen wo
wir über solche projekte reden können in
der champions league der sportwagen kann
man sich keine fehler in design erlauben
zumal man bei den geringen stückzahlen
jeden verlust an die konkurrenz spürt so
gilt es mit einer innovativen
modellpolitik gerade die fahrer des
dauer gegners ferrari mit extravaganz
und einem anderen image auf den stier zu
bringen ein schwieriges unterfangen da
viele ferraristi von geburt an auf rot
geeicht sind
wir sind dazu da um träume vielleicht
träumen die die leute noch nicht
geträumt haben zu realisieren dafür
steht die marke lamborghini auch in
zukunft gleich in der turbo reportage
die klassiker von lamborghini die heros
der 60er und 70er im werksmuseum werden
die träume der vergangenen jahrzehnte
attraktiv in szene gesetzt wahre schätze
mit einem unvorstellbaren wert keiner
kennt die rassigen stiere in der arena
besser als valentino balboni er ist das
lebende geschichtsbuch von lamborghini
die unsere erste prototyp und wir haben
am anfang ein bisschen probleme gehabt
weil war vorerst erfahrung mit so einem
auto aber wir wollten immer
[Musik]
exklusives ein lamborghini welt in
zukunft orientieren
deswegen wollten wir so genau zu bauen
mit mit flug tour das ist die erste auto
nicht so eine flugzeit um die die
niedrigste auto der welt
zurück und zwar nicht so ein auto
vorgefahren sind sie diese so tiefen wir
sind praktisch auf dem boden aber er hat
so viel erfolg
beim fahrer nicht so wie ein auto man
liegt praktisch sowie in den formel 1
auto und visibilität werde immer ein
bisschen ein problem mit kumpels
weswegen wir haben besonders so ein
system entwickeln weil man kann hier
platz nehmen sitzen pedalen bewegen und
trug gucken genau wo die ecke ist
doch nicht nur die technik hat sich
verändert auch die montage der fahrzeuge
zwar baut lamborghini kleinsten serien-
und teilweise auch limitiert ohne
fließband kommt man auch hier nicht aus
wir bauen heute hier sechs autos pro tag
und damals haben wir gebaut sechs euro
pro monat
die geworden ist sind sämtliche blieben
es ist nur mehr moderne merk
so die equipment ist ist viel anderes
konzept ist aber hier blieben und so die
angemalt
august an gemacht obwohl valentino
balboni längst in rente ist zieht in der
stallgeruch in der stierkampf-arena
lamborghini immer wieder an gerade die
jungen mechaniker schätzen sein wissen
und die umfassende erfahrung
hallo was machst du gerade hier also ich
baue hier gerade in den wagen einen sitz
ein
was genau für ein sitz
wer ein sitz mit allen raffinessen und
natürlich auch elektrisch verstellbar
com erzähl uns doch noch ein wort zu
deiner arbeit
ich kann nur sagen das beste was es auf
der welt geht ist lamborghini
die jungen männer sind von ihrer arbeit
begeistert und stolz den stier wie sie
sagen zu bauen
über 1000 einzelteile werden hier von
hand verschraubt bis der gallardo die
halle verlässt
[Musik]
wir verwenden für unsere autos nur die
besten materialien und werkstoffe die es
zur zeit auf dem wettmarkt
das ist einfach grundvoraussetzung für
den bau unserer autos
deshalb natürlich alles seinen preis und
ist nicht gerade billig
ob es wie hier zum beispiel die
aluminiumkarosserie ist
oder hier die keramik bremsen
oder das herzstück der fünf liter motor
mit einer unglaublichen kraft
die teile kommen aus aller welt insofern
ist es natürlich auch eine logistische
herausforderung
dass jedes teil zum richtigen zeitpunkt
auch hier an der produktionsstraße ist
jan o
da opera tore
angefangen hat alles noch mit einer
kleinen dreh und montage bank an der
ferrucio lamborghini mit seinem team den
ersten prototyp zusammenschraubt
[Musik]
und was forums marken und ich erinnere
vieles viel mal wenn wir auto geliefert
war wenn es spät am abend
mit verletzungen von biene wieder sind
sie immer hier auf die hauptstraße und
um diese wunderschöne motorraum unserer
linie die man die gänge gesetz erst das
zweite dritter fünfter jahren und jedes
mal wirkungen die fünfte gang eingelegt
war für unsere moral hat immer gesagt
okay jetzt funktioniert alles in ordnung
motor bekommen wir erst nach hause und
morgen wieder zurück mit den so führt er
immer gekämpft weil er wollte immer mehr
exklusiv sein und insofern hat ihnen
gesagt ich bin rennfahrer und einem
traktor fahrer gerade die high society
war von den neuen kreationen entdeckt
vor allem das design war für die feine
gesellschaft ein kaufargument
daran hat sich auch bis heute nichts
geändert wer einen lamborghini sein
eigen nennt gehört gewiss zum
establishment
so ist ein lamborghini damals wie heute
ein statussymbol
nur für testfahrer valentino balboni ist
das nichts anderes als ein
hervorragendes auto
einen lamborghini zu fahren ist für ihn
alltag
in 1 wert
[Musik]
ich habe angefangen aus testfahrer
eine von den letzten jahren das wir
gemacht haben
ja da aus
du hast
liegt die politik
denn computer die grenzwerte messen und
analysieren gab es damals noch nicht
also musste valentino am steuer den
stier höchstpersönlich zeigen wo seine
grenzen sind
die frage von upstream
sehr wichtig
spuren
wieder geht
was man
gleich in der turbo reportage patrick
simon trifft auf valentino balboni zu
seiner zeit war der miura das maß aller
dinge auf dem asphalt heute ist es der
murciélago der die messlatte bei
lamborghini nach oben legt der lp 640
wird neben der coupé form auch als
roadster sowie in limitierter auflage
als versace modell gebaut das biest ist
auch ein fall für turbo testfahrer
patrick simon er trifft im cockpit auf
sein großes vorbild valentino balboni
[Musik]
bei einem grinsen im gesicht haben
jahren gab es kein tag wo er nicht
bereut hat fest vor
aber sobald mit einem supersportwagen
sitzt man kann es nicht lassen oder es
muss immer vorwärts gehen
immer geschwindigkeit war
im osmanischen reich
es ist nicht gefährlich gewesen auf
diesen öffentlichen straßen mit solchen
ps monstern um die ecke zu fliegen
aber warum weniger verkehr
wenige auf der straße
aber hand aufs herz wie viel lamborghini
sind bei den testfahrten draufgegangen
da manchmal
valentino balboni ist eine extrem
lässige sommer ist ein ganz ganz cooler
zeitgenosse war ja auch schon ein paar
lenzen auf dem buckel 42 jahre
lamborghini testfahrers und setzt sich
in den einmal rein und bretter davon das
ist einfach den juckt das einfach alles
gar nicht mit einer entspanntheit einer
an der gelassenheit ich glaube der hat
richtig will die jahre mit lamborghini
durchlebt und ist ja mittlerweile auch
nicht nur unter lambo fenster legende
selbst ferrari testfahrer halten an
drehen um ihm einmal die hand zu
schütteln patrick darf jetzt selbst ans
steuer und auf den spuren von valentino
balboni seine runden drehen
640 ps 600 liter hubraum und
zwölfzylinder sind zahlen die sich
letztlich auch auf eine große zahl an
der kasse summieren
hamburg lebt durch seine durch sein
sound in zwölf in den brüll times vor
das ist einfach nur megageil
was macht das auto aus
kein radio der erste gang gibt es 110
die lenkung ist bisschen schärfer die
bremsen sind so effektiv unglaublich
30 ps mehr einfach mehr luft jetzt nach
vorne
100 kilogramm leichter soll er sein
damit reduziert sich das
leistungsgewicht von
28 auf 26
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein
wem brachial noch nicht reicht und
extrem brachial will der geht in den
feinkostladen von lamborghini tuning
lautet das zauberwort ja auch das gibt
es für den lambo ein team in deutschland
darf dem stier noch mehr leistung unter
die hörner geben breiter engineering der
lamborghini spezialist hans reiter weiß
wie man einen stier zum tanzen bringt
[Musik]
das
logo der auf basis des ergebnisses
rennwagens gebaut wurde das heißt wenn
man hier jede menge rennsporttechnik
angefangen von innen von 10 sitzen über
carbon lenkrad vorne haben sehen sie
diese schwarzen kiemen das dann so
genannte luft ist da wären die rathäuser
entlüftet um mehr abtrieb zu erzeugen
was haben einen kleinen splitter was
mich ja nicht sehen kann der komplette
unterboden jetzt mit einer carbon platte
geschlossen um perfekte glaubte fläche
zu bilden das gibt noch mal mehr
downforce also abtrieb im vergleich zum
serienauto unter höhere
endgeschwindigkeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bleibt die frage offen was mit den
rennboliden mit über 650 ps im rücken am
ende der saison passiert
[Musik]
und kann alle kaufen
du weißt preisen unterschiede gibt dass
er geht hier eins kann man nur in der
weltmeisterschaft fahren und da gibt es
auch nur für autos
überhaupt mit der welt gibt es nur 15
marcel ago geht die 1 und das werden
auch nicht mehr und die kosten nicht
mehr sagt heinz kostete gute halbe
million plus mehrwertsteuer wunder gt3
den verkaufen der relativ blick also
warum jetzt glaube ich
habe ich mich fest 65 oder 67 autos
verkauft
damit die boliden ihre kraft optimal auf
der rennstrecke entfalten können sind
bis zu 20 mechaniker und ingenieure im
einsatz was hier versäumt wird kann im
rennen nicht mehr nachgeholt werden
entsprechend angespannt sind die männer
in und an der box
[Musik]
in richtung sender damals habe ich kurz
darunter fehler nicht unnötig auto
riskieren oder auto wegwerfen sondern es
geht beim testen
ich fahre etwas einen technischen stand
womöglich kleinbauern das
andere flügel einstellen angreifen und
man sieht dann umgekehrt geht es
schneller mit der gleichen
prozentualen anteil und risiko ja es
sollte man die fahrenheit im test 95 bis
98 prozent beim rennen von san 100 wobei
fairerweise muss 100 prozent bei uns ja
auch nicht um 19 uhr in crawley zeigen
sich hundertprozentig auf
das chassis sowie auf motoren und
getriebe wirken enorme kräfte der
kleinste fehler der mechaniker kam zum
unfall führen
[Musik]
wir haben uns zerlegt werden werden nach
jedem rennen zerlegtes auf chance und
wenn ich jedes bauteil in die hand nehme
und putze dann habe ich es gesehen
inspiziert und ich weiß dass auch dieses
bauteil ist in ordnung ist ein fachmann
arbeitet gründlicher und gründlich
arbeiten ist am renault sehr wichtig sie
müssen vorstellung der straße zu kaufen
viva la molina das gibt doch die
qualitätskontrolle und ab dann ist
dieses auto sicher ein rennauto wird
nach jedem rennen und tausende von
teilen zerlegt und wieder zusammengebaut
die mechaniker haben dabei rissen
verantworten weil letztendlich sind die
renner vordergrund der fährt 300 damit
und
[Musik]
ständiger begleiter für die ingenieure
ist der laptop ohne ihn geht den
motorsport nichts mehr hier werden alle
daten erfasst und ausgewertet
[Musik]
und auch die beliebte musik zum beispiel
jetzt die mutter im blut und abdriften
anfängt das eigentliche problem besteht
oder auch
verschiedene fahrer vergleichen
auch die fahrer sind ein wichtiger
baustein in der fehleranalyse und
diagnose
sie sind ein seismograph der jedoch von
den einzelnen teams unterschiedliche
bedeutung zugemessen wird
grundsätzlich verlassen und fast nur auf
die technik oder die techniker also
gefordert
oder wasser gespürt hat und die
techniker versuchen
gleich in der turbo reportage die
corrida lamborghini das lambo festival
mit über 10.000 ps
lamborghini die diva in der
rennsportszene hatte nie die ganz großen
erfolge seit dem reiter engineering
seine schwarzen biester auf die
rennstrecken schickt steht die marke
immer öfter in den siegerlisten und das
wird einmal im jahr ausgiebig mit den
fans bei der corrida lamborghini
gefeiert stiere aus ganz europa treffen
sich in der corrida der stierkampfarena
ein lamborghini festival mit tollen
autos und eben solchen geschichten ihrer
stolzen besitzer ein dass jetzt jemand
gutes stück oder coupé 250 baujahr 1973
nach zylindermotor 2,5 kubik
220 ps hat zwar nicht mehr ganz aber das
ist mein gutes herzstück und das will
ich auch nie hergeben mal schon
jahrelang in familienbesitz und
hatte lange geschichte hatte mein vater
gehört der dann 90ern leider verstorben
ist und dann haben wir den über umwegen
wieder aufbauen können und somit liegt
haben unser ganzes herzblut meines
bruders turnier dran und vielen leider
natürlich auch ein paar teile dass wir
jetzt auch noch dran die so ein bisschen
herz bekommen aber ich die wahl hätte
zwischen diesem auto aus den 17 jahren
und diesen wahnsinnig tollen neuen
weißen gallardo würde ich natürlich
immer für dieses auto entscheiden weil
da ist vielleicht schon ein bisschen
kromer man da schaut die ganze
silhouette ist chrome das ist eine
richtig schöne gestylt italienische
bertone form so wie sie eigentlich immer
sein musste also wenn man macht dann
hört man wahrscheinlich immer noch
verrutschen genießt traktoren geräusch
und viele
aber dann merkt man natürlich den
hochdrehenden 18
es ist natürlich kein pflegeleichter
golfs normalerweise fahre aber mit ein
wenig sauer fachkenntnis oder im
bekanntenkreis
mechanikern die sich der auskennt da man
so ein auto noch ganz gut fliegen und
natürlich auch auf dem salzburgring
fahren wo sonst hat man als privatfahrer
schon mal die möglichkeit seinen wagen
bis an die grenzen zu bringen und
hautnah mit den profis über die curbs zu
jagen das weiß keiner besser als renn
pilot albert von thurn und taxis
[Musik]
also leider ist es so dass in den
seltensten fällen der endverbraucher vom
[Musik]
dann werden die meisten august
schnelle fahren gedacht sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr schade
[Musik]
seele
fahren werden und schon richtig
hergenommen werden und 7 dafür sind
wieder zum training
[Musik]
für mich
ist das sehr schön
kritik
[Musik]
um das rennwochenende herum ist alles
auf rennfahren gepolt vom fitness
training im fitnessstudio bis hin zur
testrunde auf dem auf dem auflaufen auf
der teststrecke
also es ist wirklich alles einfach es
ist es orientiert sich alles an dem
einen und ja das ist natürlich auch ein
luxus den man sich leisten können muss
und ich habe halt natürlich auch andere
verpflichtungen insofern ist das einfach
schwierig anders für seinen kollegen
peter kox er ist berufsfahrer und kann
sich ausschließlich auf den rennsport
konzentrieren
die beiden teilen sich ein auto und
fahren zusammen in der gt3 klasse der
holländer startet aber auch mit dem
murciélago in der gt1-klasse ein
hightech bolide mit 650 ps
ausschließlich gezüchtet für die
rennstrecken dieser welt
minimalismus gepaart mit extremen
[Musik]
das auto ist eigentlich gar nicht mehr
standard das einzige was wirklich
standard ist ist das was original sein
und das chassis also dass das das rohren
rahmen das ist standard und der rest ist
eigentlich alles modifiziert alles ist
komplett ausgebaut
das auto hat kohlefaser bremsscheiben
er hat andere radaufhängungen viele
andere aerodynamik teile am auto sind da
dran
wir haben dann auch andere
windschutzscheibe nicht hin vom plastik
ist das viel leichter das auto wegen nur
1200 kilo
hinten haben wir den mut und natürlich
schwer modifiziert wir haben jetzt 650
ps leistung mit einer mit einem kleinen
er ist rektor und sie aber natürlich
hinter einem sehr großen flügel
auflaufen das ist auch gerade für
abhebungen spät zu bleiben
das einzige was du mit diesem auto nicht
tun könnte ist das ist langsam fahren
das auto ist ausgelegt für sehr schnell
zu fahren und wo normale leute durch die
stadt fahren mit mit zwischen 1000 und
3000 umdrehungen da wird dieses auto
sehr schwierig zu fahren sein also ich
denke du wirst mit einem fiat boden
durch schneller durch die stadt fahren
können wir mit unserem auto weil wir nur
in die höheren drehzahlbereich gefahren
und dass die motoren leute die motoren
bauen gar kein interesse habe wie der
motor läuft bei bei 1 oder 2000 und dann
ist es natürlich schwierig damit zu
fahren oder schaust du nicht auto fahren
kann so wird das auto hin und her
brocken also dass schon ein bisschen
komisch aussah es gibt nur wenige
serienfahrzeuge auf der welt die es mit
diesem rennsportler aufnehmen könnten
einer kommt aus dem gleichen stall der
lamborghini reventón
hier sieht man natürlich die speerspitze
italienischer handwerkskunst im
automobilbereich von lamborghini der
lamborghini reventón nur 20 stück gebaut
alle schon vor
fabrikations ende verkauft und ist
natürlich ein hammer geschoss wenn man
sich den so anschaut und sie natürlich
aus wie ein kampfjet da gab es auch
tolle der gleiche gegenüber von aldi
zusammen gestartet sind waren sie ins
auto würde ich natürlich auch gerne
fahren aber für die knappe millionen die
man dafür hinlegen muss da zahle ich
doch lieber meine 400 euro steuern und
ab und zu meinem neuen ölwechsel war im
alten lamborghini miura co und
würde dann doch diesen vorziehen auch
wenn das ein wahnsinnig tolles auto ist
aber was alt ist es auch schön
nur 20 stück wurden vom reventón gebaut
ähnlich limitiert wurde auch die
stückzahl dieser sonderedition
[Musik]
hier steht man natürlich vom ganz
speziellen fahrzeug das ist der
lamborghini gallardo lp 550-2 eine
sonderedition die valentino balboni
editionen benannt nach dem legendären
testfahrer von lamborghini von diesem
fahrzeug gibt es weltweit nur 250 stück
dieses fahrzeug hat 550 ps und
unterscheidet sich zu den normalen gar
dass dadurch dass es nur
hinterradantrieb hat dieses fahrzeug ist
auch nochmals speziell dargestellt hat
spezielle felgen hatten speziellen
innenraum und wir sehen hier oben auch
noch mal diesen speziellen streifen
gleich in der turbo reportage sammler
aus leidenschaft wir öffnen eine echte
lambo schatz kamera
schon jetzt ist der valentino balboni
ein beliebtes objekt unter sammlern und
wird weit über dem herstellerpreis
gehandelt jedoch kein vergleich zu
seinem urgroßvater dem 450 g t von dem
nur noch wenige fahrzeuge weltweit
existieren entsprechend hoch sind
nachfrage und preis
eine davon ist im besitz von alexander
wiesner der experte und kenner der marke
hat seine eigene private corrida
[Musik]
dieses modell war der erste mann ist ja
der erfolg von der firma lamborghini das
ist das modell 400 gt 2 + 2
es wurden
exemplare hergestellt
die stadt bis 1968
mit dem 4 liter aggregat und zwölf
zylindern schiebt der wagen in 6,4
sekunden auf 100 km h
da wagen wird aus den vorgängertypen 350
gt und 400 g
22 deshalb weil da hinten noch in zwei
notsitze hat
dem tauglich
der 450 g t wurde von 1966 bis 1968
gebaut und setzte insbesondere durch
seine elegante erscheinung sowie das
hochwertige und luxuriöse interieur für
einen sportwagen zeichen er war auch das
letzte auto mit einer initialen
kennzeichnung im anschluss trugen die
fahrzeuge die namen berühmter stiere
oder stier züchter wie zum beispiel dem
jura er verdankt seinen namen dem
berühmten kampfstier züchter eduardo
miura
ausgangspunkt für das logo war jedoch
das sternzeichen von ferruccio
lamborghini
er war stets das besondere an diesem
jahr ist
dass der motor
eingebaut ist 115 der motor der quer
eingebaut ist die zwar hinter der
fahrgastzelle und das ist eine sensation
gewesen aber den 60er jahren und wurde
vom publikum aufgenommen
und hier das lieblingsauto von ferruccio
lamborghini der yamaha er wurde ab dem
jahr 1970 in sant'agata gebaut
[Musik]
leider bei der ihr aber kein
kommerzieller erfolg es wurden nur 177
stück von diesem modell produziert über
23 jahre lang obwohl es einige sehr
schöne fahrendes auto hat dann nur wenig
zwölfzylinder motor und vier bietern
[Musik]
ja wo ist meine leidenschaft zur
lamborghini entstanden ist dass eine
firma die zur peter autos sowie die
modelle gebaut hat die sehr
unterschiedlich sind die
verschiedene grad der ansprechenden
partie fahrer typen ansprechen so dass
jeweils einen schönen formen der 60er
jahre
bis zu den 80ern mit dem kantigen kinn
touch
auffällig
extrovertierten charakter ist ein
fahrzeug dabei war lamborghini und das
macht es interessant
der countach zählt zu den auffälligsten
modellen von lamborghini er hielt sich
mit 14 jahren bauzeit auch am längsten
am markt von ihm wurden auch zahlreiche
spezialversionen wie zum beispiel der l
p 500 oder der konterrevolution
hergestellt im gegensatz zum espada oder
yamaha war er ein reinrassiger sportler
dem jura war damals eine sensation und
marcello gandini bei der tour hatte die
aufgabe einen nachfolger zu kreieren
ich denke es ist ihm gelungen auch
dieser wagen ist eine sensation der
kunde hat es minus 273 totale leute
waren hin und weg von der keilform ist
dort auch zwei jahre bis dann die
produktion an lief aber es wurden
immerhin knapp 2.000 stück davon
produziert waren finanzieller erfolg für
lamborghini
aber mit dem kot touch kam auch das ende
von ferruccio lamborghini als autobauer
und chef des unternehmens
nachdem
472 zurückgezogen hatte hat er sich den
beiden an bord zugewendet
und dies mit erfolg
heute steht das werk unter der obhut von
audi und schreibt dank einer
erfolgreichen modellpolitik und der
positiven resonanz aus dem motorsport
wieder schwarze zahlen ein garant
hierfür albert von thurn und taxis der
27 jährige student betreibt den sport
bislang nur als hobby
von klein auf den gehweg habe aber nicht
fahren dürfen dafür durften
gemeinsam mit seinem kollegen peter kox
besteigt er immer öfter das siegerpodest
der holländer ist für den prinz ein
vorbild und wichtiger partner im team er
gibt die fahrlinien vor und ist auch
sprachrohr beim setup und teilen
und dann ist da natürlich sehr wichtig
dass sie schnell ein und aussteigt das
ist natürlich
vor jedem rennen herrscht höchste
konzentration
die anspannung bei fahrer und team ist
spürbar reiter engineering ist bei jedem
event favorit nichts wird dem zufall
überlassen das cockpit wird zum
arbeitsplatz und
dann haben wir die wichtigste bedingung
sagte wieder radio so gar nicht mit der
box produzieren während peter kox die
erste hälfte des einstündigen rennens
bestreitet fiebert albert gemeinsam mit
dem team in jeder runde mit der
countdown für seinen einsatz läuft in
wenigen minuten kämpft er wieder um den
sieg für den studenten der
volkswirtschaft und theologie ist es
immer wieder eine herausforderung gegen
die absoluten rennprofis auf der strecke
zu bestehen um so erstaunlicher ist es
dass er ohne regelmäßiges training auf
dem kurs mithalten kann es ist schon auf
jeden fall ein großer vor allem der chef
hat gesagt volles risiko wir brauchen
punkte
und dass es dann das sind dafür klare
anweisungen
dies dann auch zu befolgen
es ist soweit nach 30 minuten springt
albert von thurn und taxis in das 500 ps
gefährt jetzt erlebt man die andere
seite des prinzen keine spur mehr vom
fürstenhaus protokoll oder feiner
etikette jetzt ist er der rennfahrer
albert der sich mit den anderen herren
zum knallharten rennsport trifft und
misst ich weiß nur dass bei mir wirklich
von von kindesbeinen an autos und
motoren und
drumrum waren meine ersten worte laut
meiner mutter
und mit brumm brumm bestreitet er heute
erfolgreich profirennen durch seine
rolle als fürst von thurn und taxis und
den damit verbundenen verpflichtungen
und aufgaben wird dieser sport für ihn
wohl immer ein hobby bleiben die rolle
als pilot hat jedoch auch sein
bewusstsein für verantwortung
zuverlässigkeit disziplin und letztlich
auch teamgeist gestärkt er ist hinter
dem steuer positiv gereift
erst privat schon auch sehr ehrgeizig
private gleiche menschen auf der
rennstrecke dies können kollegen sowie
mitarbeiter im team nur bestätigen er
ist ein teil eines eingespielten
räderwerk zwar sitzt albert am steuer
und steht auf dem podest sein dank gilt
aber stets den ingenieuren und
mechanikern
reiter engineering ist ein kleines
gewachsenes unternehmen mit einer fast
familiären atmosphäre ein grund warum
sich albert von thurn und taxis hier
auch wohl und aufgehoben fühlt vor jedem
rennen wird nicht nur die technik
sondern auch die geschwindigkeit und das
teamwork beim boxenstopp trainiert wer
hier schläft hat verloren
es ist lange her dass lamborghini so
konstant erfolge nach hause gefahren hat
aber anscheinend sind nicht nur auto
mechaniker und fahrer sondern auch ein
echter glücksbringer mit entscheidend
für den sieg die eigene mutter ist
offensichtlich garant für ein gloria im
team reiter
[Musik]
es ist wirklich wie verhext jedes mal
wenn ich mal dabei ist springt
eigentlich ein podium dabei raus
gelassen und stets freundlich gibt
albert seinen fans autogramme keine spur
von unnahbaren fürsten er ist ein kerl
ein rennfahrer zum anfassen eine
persönlichkeit hinter dem lenkrad und
gewiss auch eine bereicherung für den
rennsport
[Musik]
ferruccio lamborghini starb am 20
februar 1993 und hat die größten erfolge
seiner marke nicht mehr miterlebt aber
die legende lamborghini lebt weiter
[Musik]
[Applaus]